hello everyone and welcome to a video
where I will briefly try to explain what
happened yesterday and well how-how-how
the podcast was even taken down now the
podcast was set to air as a live
premiere which is the same as basically
uploading a video only it allows me and
the viewers to watch the video
simultaneously while chatting and then
after it premieres after the entire
video is over then it just turns into a
regular video and everything was going
perfectly normal I think it was at the
round 1 hour and 20 minute mark that the
video was taken down I started receiving
messages that no one can see the video
that the video has been taken down and
people have started sending me our
screenshots of why I was taken down due
to well not abiding to YouTube the
guideline policy and I was like what and
well I went went to my YouTube dashboard
and it seems that I received a guideline
strike so here as you can see this is
what what you see if you if you click on
the link for the podcast this live
stream recording is not available we've
removed this video because it violates
our Community Guidelines you'll be able
to view this video for seven days from
when it was removed this period allows
you to review the content and decide
whether you wish to submit an appeal and
I click submit an appeal instantly
without even needing to review what was
in the video because I mean I made the
video I know what's in it and I know it
doesn't violate any Community Guidelines
and the eye I clicked appeal this
decision and like 30 seconds later maybe
a minute later the appeal was rejected
so as you can see here it says appeal
rejected yesterday so it was like I
clicked appeal and then it was
immediately rejected so what's happened
what happened here my video was not
taken down because a human employee of
YouTube said okay this is some harmful
and dangerous content let's just I mean
let's take it down it was done by a by
an algorithm that maybe heard some some
keywords that are not appropriate for
the current situation in the world and
decided to take it out in the video
but yeah as you can see here a people
rejected a policy harmful ordained
dangerous content now here are above you
can see warning your content was removed
due to a violation of our Community
Guidelines because it's the first time
your account isn't affected you're only
warned once and this warning will remain
on your channel so the the penalty for a
Community Guidelines strike isn't like
something all that serious the the
penalties that I would not be able to
upload post or live stream for a week
and since this is a fairly busy Channel
one week for me is a lot and the thing
is I've uploaded more almost 1,800
videos over the course of three years
that are being very active on YouTube
and in those almost 1800 videos there
wasn't a single Community Guidelines
violation or anything and it just seems
super weird that YouTube would I mean I
already uploaded like 1800 videos don't
you have like a green list or white list
like this is a this is a fine channel
let's not you know just allow both to do
their thing and I still have no idea why
I was taken down and still nothing has
changed I mean I slept on it and I
realized they have other stuff to do of
course they can just you know bring all
of their attention to one channel
especially one it's not even like okay
I'm not I'm like I'm not like a huge
channel I have almost 700,000
subscribers but I'm not I'm not I'm not
like a small Channel so it does seem
weird and still people have had some
ideas like why how this could have
happened like maybe the YouTube
algorithm heard some I don't know
there's talk of like racism like if okay
maybe if YouTube algorithm whistle it
was really an idiot then maybe maybe
could have heard something like okay in
this line of the Berlin maybe if black
goes v6 instead of c6 white will always
be better and then maybe with the
current situation in the world if he
hears something like that white will
always be better it might flag this
video as inappropriate harmful or
dangerous and take it down but if that's
the case then I am pretty sure all of my
1800 videos will be taking down as it's
pretty much black against white
every every video and I don't think it's
supposed to work like that another thing
is there is this policy now that YouTube
doesn't allow youtubers to address the
current situation in the world I'm not
even gonna mention the situation because
this video might also be taken down
however it's the situation that forces
people to stay indoors that forces
people and they're not allowed to go
outside and the only the only time when
we mentioned this during the podcast was
well was why chess is experiencing its
new renaissance why why are so many
people in the chest now because they are
in their homes more than they were like
maybe a few months back and they have
more time on their hands interestings
like a perfectly reasonable thing to
start maybe you haven't played chess for
for for a couple of years or maybe even
for 20-30 years and now you're in your
home you have a computer pretty much
everyone does and it's very easy to
start the chess again we don't have have
to have like super strong machine to
play new video games that are coming out
you can pretty much play chess on
anything on any smartphone any PC and
and that's basically it we haven't
addressed this issue in any in any
aspect other than that I mean I realize
if for example now some channels would
say that okay you should do this and
then that will cure that situation or
something like that some we're giving
people weird advice okay I realized that
the dad kind of content needs to be
taken down because it can be harmful and
dangerous but this is this is a chess
podcast and it's such a shame because a
lot of work went into it it's not I mean
you have to organize everything you have
to prepare everything you have to I mean
record have said it and it's just it's
just a shame and I don't know the third
possibility would be like during this
life premiere that a lot of people have
flagged it as a violent or inappropriate
and then a YouTube's algorithm
immediately took it down which also
makes no sense to me I mean that way
that way you could pretty much take any
video down no questions asked and it it
really is weird like okay if I was like
a new channel
with maybe 10 videos no one no one knows
the algorithm didn't learn that this is
a normal channel that doesn't do
anything I mean III don't even swear in
my videos I don't
there's no profanity there's no there is
no inappropriate content of any kind and
if if if such a podcast can be taken
down it's well it's hard to even find
motivation to continue doing something
like that
now I do expect this to be resolved and
I do expect the the video to be brought
back maybe tomorrow on Monday when
someone you know goes to work and
manually reviews it because you know you
do have to now like sit down and watch
the entire thing it's like over an hour
and a half but I mean I see no no way
around that and yeah while addressing it
as I did address it briefly on Twitter
but most of the most you guys don't have
Twitter so that's why I'm also doing it
here and the podcast is available on
other platforms like it's available on
Spotify on Google podcast Apple podcast
and on buzzsprout so I will put some
link in the description below if you
guys are interested in listening to it
if you maybe haven't watched it until
the end but even though that's fine
YouTube is my main platform and I really
am a big fan of video so I do really do
hope it gets reinstated but if not
probably will upload it to some other
platform so you guys can can check that
out as well but yeah that's pretty much
it what I what I wanted to mention and
yeah hope let's hope it just comes back
and that you know things like this don't
happen in the future as it's really it's
really frustrating wait you've done
nothing wrong and even though that
Community Guidelines strike isn't really
doing all that much it's it's merely a
warning for the moment it really it's
really frustrating when you when you
upload 1,800 videos and then you get
like a Community Guidelines strike for
for harmful and dangerous content out of
nowhere and there is content on YouTube
I mean there is a lot of content on
YouTube that would deserve this
guideline strike before a casual
conversation with Hikaru Nakamura so
that's that's the video I do hope you
enjoyed it and
somewhat somewhat explain what happened
and yeah we're continuing with the
chasuble masters see you soon guys